[Musik]
die app musical gibt es irgendwie nicht
mehr und das ganze heißt jetzt tick tock
und dort wert eigentlich genau das
gleiche hochgeladen damals auch beim
musical einfach kurze videos von
irgendwelchen leuten die auf einen
vorgefertigtes lied irgendwelche
tanzbewegungen machen da ihren mund mit
zu bewegen und auch sowie beim musical
gibt es auch bei tecdoc übelste prinz
videos die dort hochgeladen werden und
ist bereits mit cher eingeblendet ich
reagiere heute auftrieb denn ich habe
mir eine compilation rausgesucht und
zwar keine geringere als die ultimate
tik tok queens compilation
[Musik]
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich möchte in
diesem video keine personen aufgrund
ihres aussehens fertig machen oder sonst
irgendwie was aber ich denke dass sie
das ganze nicht wirklich ernst meint
das mit dem schwachsinn in ruhe war kein
scheiß ich glaube damit wollte er die
leute zum lachen bringen das ist das ist
auf jeden fall gelungen
was ist das jetzt für eine kranke
scheiße gerade den kopf habe ich auch
ultra häufig unter tik tok videos
gelesen dass auf dieser plattform sehr
viele pädophile komische menschen
unterwegs sind also kinder wenn ihr auf
der plattform tik tok unterwegs seid
folgt am besten nur diesem account
ach du scheiße sind da noch meine alten
musical ist eigentlich online
nicht auf meinen account
[Musik]
was denkt man sich denn da war sowas
hochzuladen ganz mehr
[Musik]
drei wochen später
es sieht so aus als hätte er daran gar
sind spaß
[Musik]
warum zeigt
steht ich will nicht falsch ich möchte
hier niemanden angreifen oder so solche
videos für mich wirklich privat geheim
silben obwohl ich eigentlich gar nichts
sagen darf
[Musik]
sorry da sehen wir unterbrechen aber
diese person ist diese typische art von
music ally mensch ich meine warum
gestreckt man hier seine zu das aus
das muss man bei dem song nicht tun um
dieses wort auszusprechen
[Musik]
ja
die auch noch irgendwelche dinge
einsetzen lassen als solcher augen hat
nur ein alien
also erstmal muss ich wirklich sagen ich
finde dass sie entweder ist er halt ein
typ mit seiner freundin oder mit seiner
tochter kein okay das macht das ganze
wieder ein bisschen pädophilen aber die
beiden nehmen zusammen als musical auf
beziehen wir sind tipptopp mich immer
ein tick tack alt haben jetzt hab ich
immer an sich ist das ganz süß dass sie
da zusammen irgendwie was aufnehmen
vielleicht ist es auch das erste mal
dass der linke da überhaupt irgendwie
was sich mit aufnehmen und das aufkochen
die sache ist nur dieser bietet komplett
übersteuert da muss ich gar nicht mehr
ins schwimmen gehen falls meine damen
und herren
als mir das gerade angeguckt habe ich
nur gedacht hey
das könnte ich eigentlich mal nachmachen
[Musik]
470 job aufzunehmen
ein paar sekunden später wieder zurück
juli liegt wieder im bett da wo die
tatsächlich 24 stunden am tag verbringt
[Musik]
der mann muss 30
was ist das für ein hit erstmal dollar
screenshot hier das hier wieso also wird
sie sich mit dem 1
aus der seele schreiben
ich finds ja
schon echt komisch wasser für sachen
hochgeladen werden
[Musik]
ich glaube dass hier das meinten viele
leute mit komischen leuten die auf der
plattform sind wie bereits gesagt ich
will ihn überhaupt nicht irgendwie
angehen oder persönlich attackieren oder
so nicht dass das irgendwie man falsch
versteht hier aber auf tik tok sind
zwölfjährige unterwegs und noch jüngere
und er hey schaut mal ich habe pinkl
sich in dem hintergrund sitzende katze
und das shirt ist von ihrer
lieblingsserie schmeckt mir partner der
videos von euch leute passt auf jeden
fall auch bei dieser plattform
[Musik]
was war daran lustig oh mein gott
zeigt er da gerade handschellen menschen
nicht gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
[Musik]
du musst mal schauen sie krass dass aus
dem tank fliegen das jedoch klar jetzt
worden
[Musik]
ich glaube
jetzt ist auch der moment gekommen wo
ich das ganze wirklich mal beenden
sollte wenn euch meine reaktion auf
diese techcrunch compilation gefallen
hat meine damen und herren anlass gerne
mal einen leid da soll ich eventuell
nächste woche noch mal auffällt es gibt
also es gibt 40 compilation tik tok
paare 40.000 life werde ich nächste
woche auch noch mal eine reaktion auf
tik tok quincy videos hochladen hier auf
meinem kanal erkennt ihr irgendwelche
ticket kann hier auf die ich vielleicht
mal reagieren soll schreibt ohne in die
kommentare sollen julia und ich
vielleicht auch mal ein paar tik tok
videos nachstellen da gibt es auf jeden
fall viele möglichkeiten aber ich finds
auf jeden fall lustig das musical in
einer gewissen form zurück ist auch ein
ja denn die musicals hair talk talk aber
ist ja quasi jetzt gleich wie gesagt
schaut gern auch mal bei mir vorbei wenn
ihr das video sehen wollt was ich gerade
aufgenommen haben für technisch komplett
beschissen
[Musik]